[Música]
bienvenidos a 5 minutos con hoy
hablaremos sobre las personas que se han
recuperado del coi 19 que pueden
presentar más de 50 secuelas en su
organismo entre ellas la fatiga como la
más recurrente nos acompaña a rosalinda
sepúlveda médica psiquiatra y también
investigadora de la escuela de salud
pública de harvard doctora buen día
gracias por estar aquí con nosotros en
france 34 además de la fatiga que otras
secuelas son comunes en las personas que
padecieron de coach 19 y le pregunto si
algunas de estas secuelas se pueden
mantener a lo largo del tiempo que están
muy buenos días y gracias por este
espacio para compartir la investigación
en los resultados que encontramos fíjate
que empezamos a ver que al menos un
síntoma está presente en el 80% de las
personas que se recuperan de kobe
el principal como bien lo mencionas es
la fatiga el estudio que hicimos evalúa
diferentes estudios de hasta 110 días
estamos hablando un poquito más de tres
meses que las personas se siguen
sintiendo mal y siguen presentando algún
síntoma la fatiga como bien lo menciona
ese es el principal síntoma que se
presenta está en un 58 por ciento de las
personas de ahí el siguiente es dolor de
cabeza el siguiente es un le llaman
trastorno de la atención hasta en un 30
por ciento de las personas y estamos
hablando en inglés se le llama mentol
folk es un es una sensación de
aturdimiento de dificultad para seguir
un hilo de una conversación alteraciones
en la memoria alteraciones
en la atención y en la toma de
decisiones
el número 4 sería la pérdida del cabello
y luego los síntomas respiratorios que
se quedan hasta en un 25 por ciento de
las personas y el principal de eso es a
lo que se llama disnea que es la
dificultad para respirar ahora doctora y
cuáles son las técnicas de
rehabilitación y estrategias de manejo
clínico que se le pueden dar a los
pacientes para tratar de superar estas
afecciones
ahorita al menos se están creando
clínicas en todo el mundo sobre el
manejo después del gobi de estamos en un
punto de que al ser una enfermedad nueva
esta es información que está cambiando
día con día y no todavía ni siquiera se
le pone un nombre a estas a esta serie
de signos y síntomas que presentan los
pacientes recuperados este habla de algo
que como long holder socovil crónico o
síndrome post co y esto es todavía no
hay un consenso del nombre lo que sí
sabemos es que hay lugares que se están
creando en algunas partes del mundo para
atender de una manera integral estos
pacientes el tratamiento ahorita se está
enfocando más bien en la piel en cada
síntoma sí más que en un tratamiento
completo ahora hablando de la parte
psicológica cómo afecta al coach 19 a
las personas en general y no solamente a
las campas de sido la enfermedad sino
también a sus familiares y seres
queridos claro muy buena pregunta fíjate
que empezamos a encontrar también
de hecho el siguiente síntoma el número
6 son los trastornos mentales que es lo
más frecuente de esto es insomnio
demencias depresión y ansiedad
esto en general en los pacientes
recuperados de kobe pero el impacto que
está teniendo en la pandemia la
enfermera el acercamiento con la muerte
las pérdidas es algo también de grave
consideración para la salud mental no
solo de los pacientes recuperados sino
de toda la población ahora doctor a los
niños en edad escolar cómo se ven
afectados por la falta de interacción
hijo la excelente pregunta el estudio
que hicimos nosotros solamente manejaba
de personas de 18 años en adelante sin
embargo los niños también se se pueden
ver afectados por la enfermedad no de
manera tan grave con una mortalidad tan
alta pero si se están viendo casos y
reportes de casos pero tal vez no
tenemos suficiente información para
hacer un meta-análisis sin embargo el
efecto de la pandemia propiamente de las
medidas de seguridad de las medidas de
alejamiento claro que tienen un impacto
en la socialización en los efectos de
cada familia en sus casas de la
educación
y claro que va a haber un impacto y
esperemos que sea a corto plazo
sin embargo los niños se recuperan
rápido los niños tienen una excelente
capacidad de adaptarse si así es doctora
gracias por su tiempo por estar aquí con
nosotros en 5 minutos con de france 24
hasta aquí este esta sección continué
con
[Música]